أريد أن أبدأ بهذه الضربة على
قاعدة التدريب العسكرية التي كانت
كلاريسا تتحدث عنها للتو بالقرب من
منطقة الحياة على الجانب الغربي من أوكرانيا على بعد 11 ميلاً فقط
من الحدود مع بولندا ، ما
الذي يخبرك ذلك عن استراتيجية بوتين
ومدى قلقك بشأن هذه الضربة
الاقتراب جدًا من منطقة الناتو
جيدًا أولاً ، شكرًا لاستضافتي يا دانا ،
لقد حذرنا منذ فترة طويلة قبل بدء
هذا الغزو
في فبراير من أن
خطط هذا الغزو تضمنت مهاجمة روسيا في
جميع أنحاء أوكرانيا جنوب
أوكرانيا في شرق أوكرانيا ونعم غرب
أوكرانيا.  لم يكن
مفاجأة لمجتمع المخابرات
والأمن القومي الأمريكي ، ما يظهره
هو أن فلاديمير بوتين محبط
من حقيقة أن قواته لا
تحرز نوع التقدم الذي كان يعتقد
أنها ستحققه ضد
المدن الكبرى بما في ذلك كييف.  يقوم
بتوسيع عدد الأهداف التي
يهاجمها
وأنه يحاول إحداث ضرر في
كل جزء من البلاد
مع  أوضح الرئيس بايدن
منذ البداية أنه لن يكون لدينا
قوات عسكرية أمريكية تعمل في أوكرانيا
ولا يوجد أي منها يعمل هناك الآن ،
لكننا سندافع عن كل شبر من
أراضي الناتو حتى ونحن نسعى لتقديم
المساعدة العسكرية للمقاتلين الأوكرانيين.
يدافعون بشجاعة عن
منازلهم ويدافعون بشجاعة عن مدنهم